back on track with the Harry Potter
review sorry I didn't review what it's
been like two weeks these others have to
do to this week to make up for it I've
been preoccupied not just with injustice
though it is very preoccupied world [ __ ]
like [ __ ] anyhow let's talk about
Prisoner of Azkaban
[Music]
I read Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban
so Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban is the third Harry Potter film
in the Harry Potter movie franchise also
the third book and it's the first Harry
Potter that has a different director
resulting in this movie having a very
different tone during necessary for the
Harry Potter movie to evolve more on
that in a second but it's also the first
Harry Potter film to have Michael Gambon
as Albus Dumbledore yes Richard Harris
who played Dumbledore in the first two
Harry Potter films he sadly passed away
let me take a minute to talk about the
differences in the Dumbledore see
Richard Harrison Michael Gambon both
play different aspects of Albus
Dumbledore quite brilliantly the
Dumbledore in the books was very
sympathetic empathetic compassionate
he's very understanding old and wise
other things you would want your old
wizard to be but when it was time to get
[ __ ] done he straight-up got Chad done
he's very powerful and you couldn't pull
one pastor it's a very hard line to ride
to be a kind wonderful old person also
someone who's not to be crossed and you
can't take advantage of that person
because of their kindness Dumbledore in
the books perfectly exhibits the perfect
line between the two and the actors both
play different sides of him wonderfully
Richard Harris was the kind
compassionate side of Dumbledore Michael
Gambon while very understanding also
exhibited a more Stern side to
Dumbledore's like if you took Dumbledore
and had a bean split the two sides of
Dumbledore's personality Richard Harris
Dumbledore and Michael Gambon Dumbledore
would be what emerged as the two sides
of the one person and that is the beauty
of art when you're reading a book you
kind of project what you know as the
personality traits into its own self the
literary pages into your mind however
what an actor has to do is do that and
then exhibit what they interpret and
hopefully it's in line with what you see
but it isn't always actors have to make
the character their own I think both
actors did it wonderfully if you look to
personality traits of both performances
crush them into one you have Dumbledore
from the book that's my very long
tangent celebrating the performances of
Dumbledore I do this because the
importance of Dumbledore's not to be
overstated that said we have the whole
movie to talk about in Harry Potter and
the Prisoner of Azkaban Harry Potter
learns that there's this prisoner who is
escaped from Azkaban prison Azkaban is a
very bad place ultimately is where they
send bad wizards and these Dementors
just kind of SAP their souls and keep
them there yeah they're soul rivers so
you know this guy Sirius Black who is
escaped from Azkaban prison going to
cross Harry Potter's path somehow less
the fact he's played by Gary Oldman you
don't get an actor like Daario
to just not have him interact with Harry
Potter the tangled web is very much a
tangled web we weave in the stories also
the new Defense Against the Dark Arts
teacher is Remus Lupin the Harry Potter
thing is that they have a new Defense
Against the Dark Arts teacher every year
South Park would kill Kenny every
episode Harry Potter gets a new Defense
Against the Dark Arts teacher every year
these are the sticks but he's also tied
in with Harry Potter's parents and makes
them a little more relevant but as I
said before this is the first Harry
Potter movie that had a different
director Alfonso Kuran directed this
movie and you completely see the change
in tone when I first saw Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of Azkaban when it was
in theaters I was like Edie not my
favorite fact is probably my least
favorite of all of them but I said
didn't like change I guess but now under
different lenses the lenses of someone
who has learned you have to embrace
change in order to survive life and
someone who also reviews movies I
watched this movie in all my job was
dropped for a lot of it if memory serves
and granted it doesn't always this is
one of the better Harry Potter movies I
remember it's also one of the most
important to literally speaking you look
at this there are so many shots they're
magical when Harry is writing Buckbeak
the Hippogriff and his claws are just
dangling in the waters it's beautiful
there's also the imagery of the
Dementors around Hogwarts I was like I
want that painting on my wall it's
beautiful as almost a horror aspect kind
of way in terms of atmosphere and
granted you know it's not our move it's
a Harry Potter movie visually speaking
the visuals are there you see the ice
form and the flowers all dying into the
Dementors robes going by me it's very
scary and I can't overstate that in
terms of its importance the first two
Harry Potter movies had a very fun vibe
a magical vibe this was the first movie
that was like let's take it in a darker
direction granted it had to because the
books did too but the vibe and
atmosphere you see and feel in this
movie is in the Harry Potter movie
franchise until its end it was a horse
of a different color that changed the
color of all the horses to come granted
love the first two but I really love
what this movie did this is the movie
that said mad kids got to grow up the
first couple years have their place in
the mythos of magic but it can't be like
that forever
also this is the first and only movie
that doesn't really deal with Voldemort
as the main villain in the end I'm
trying to treat these reviews like you
haven't seen Harry Potter yeah and then
I try to keep them as spoiler free as
possible
long story short there's a werewolf
fight at the end
the end has this weird end chapter
tacked on to it that deals with time
you're like that is a spoiler just
saying that I said I tried and say I
always do I thought it was really cool
his chapters so heavy on family when
Harry and everyone they're all talking
in this shack at the end and you're like
holy smokes so important maybe that was
when I first saw the movie I didn't know
who these names were like there's a WHO
and a what and someone was really
important than the rat turd woohoo but
looking back now as the names are every
bit as recognizable as Wicked Witch of
the West Darth Vader I may be not Darth
Vader
definitely bib Fortuna though when they
start throwing this name at you halfway
through the movie you're like I'd know
who he oh okay yeah dude is a dick guys
in the end Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban I would have told you before
rewatching these movies it was one of my
least favorite Harry Potter movies now
it's one of my most favorite it's in its
own classes like emo kid it's like
whatever I'm different than you guys and
it actually is the Draco Malfoy rivalry
has never been more irrelevant the
imagery has never been more interesting
than more magical in other chapters but
not as interesting as this one like I
said I say as memory serves going
forward who knows we're going to be like
no no no no order of the Phoenix
actually had that greatest imagery as
here right now Prisoner of Azkaban just
baffled me blew me away how memory had
failed me so much if you watched the
Prisoner of Azkaban back in the day
you're like I didn't really fight with
me I really encourage you give it a
second chance it's an interesting take
with great tone and a new fame John
Williams still did the score in this
movie but it has a new theme I mean has
the old one too but it also has this new
one when the end credits were rolling I
was just sitting there listening to it
going oh my gosh I have no recollection
of this theme it really should create
peace it shows that Harry Potter ages
with people it's not like I'll
perpetually kids books it's kids are
growing up and now there's this old so
they can handle this I'm just going to
say it Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban to my surprise is awesome to
Acula
alright guys when Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban have you seen it
what did you think about it was your
favorite part in the movie whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]